bonjour claude blanchemaison merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin sur
rtl france alors que demande la zean à
la birmanie justement qu at elle demandé
au cours de ce sommet spécial consacré à
cette crise eh bien écoutez contre toute
attente le sommet de l'adn s'est mis
d'accord samedi soir sur cinq points qui
sont assez allant premier point c'est la
cessation immédiate de toute violence
le deuxième point c'est d'ouverture d un
dialogue avec toutes les parties
concernées au myanmar
le troisième point c'est le fait que
l'asian veut exercer une médiation
le quatrième point c'est qu'un envoyé
spécial de l'asian sera désigné à cette
fin et qu'il devrait avoir accès
naturellement à toutes les parties au
conflit au myanmar et le cinquième point
c'est que la zad veut pouvoir acheminer
de l'aide alimentaire à la population
birmane alors c'est cinq points ont été
acceptées par tous les participants
puisque latéral fonctionne suivant la
règle du consensus y compris le général
mimine anglaise qui était venu le chef
de la junte qui était venu non pas en
tant que chef d'état mais en tant que
chef d'état major chef des armées et il
a participé à ce sommet et il a accepté
le consensus sur ces cinq quoi il a
juste obtenu qu'une figure pas un
sixième point que certains participants
avaient demandé et qui a été la
libération des prisonniers politiques la
guide a fait quand même un peu beaucoup
et ce point n'a été évoqués figurent
dans le compte rendu de la présidence
mais ne figure pas dans le consensus
alors quand claude on peut on peut donc
lire qu'est-ce qu'il ya eu consensus
finalement des états de l'asian sur les
demandes vis-à-vis de la birmanie si oui
alors d'abord il faut dire que ce sommet
était présidée par le sultan de brunei
puisque c'est grenaille
il suit à la bonne taille qui exerça
cette année la présidence de la zad qui
se tenait en indonésie parce que c'est
l'indonésie qui à l'été était la plus
allante pour essayer de trouver une
solution politique à cette crise berman
est d'ailleurs le premier ministre les
premiers ministres de de l'indonésie
monsieur locaux vides au dos s'est
montré très actif pendant la séance et a
demandé avec véhémence au général chef
de la junte de faire cesser
immédiatement toutes les violences
il a été épaulé d'ailleurs dans cette
démarche par le premier ministre de la
malaisie qui lui aussi considère que ce
qui se passe en birmanie est extrêmement
dangereux pour l'équilibré en asie du
sud est également pour la prospérité
économique de cette région du monde
alors il y avait également présents le
premier ministre de singapour
les deux premiers de singapour à la
surprise un peu de tout le monde à
exiger la libération de valabre mme suu
kyi ce premier ministre et d'autres que
le fils de monsieur lee kuan yew
l'inventeur de singapour
et puis il y avait aussi le premier
ministre le nouveau premier ministre du
vietnam qui faisait là sa première
sortie internationale et qui a également
fait état de des soucis de singapour
pour la stabilité de la région et a
demandé que ces troubles s'est s'est par
conséquent qui est ouverture d un
dialogue inclusif
donc c'est assez surprenant que dans le
fond des représentants de régime aussi
diverses soit intervenu dans le même
sens et sommes arrivés à un consensus
alors il y avait trois absents le
premier ministre thaïlandais qui est lui
même issu d'un coup d'état militaire est
probablement keppra utah a préféré ne
pas participer à ce sommet mais la
thaïlande était représenté et elle a
participé au consensus
de la même façon le président philippe
pas
venu contexte ans lui aussi la crise du
que vides et ainsi que le premier
ministre du laos
trois absents mais qui ont participé au
consensus et qui tissera pas opposé
puisqu'il avait des représentants
donc on voit bien que la zean dans le
fond évolué qu'elle évolue en prenant un
rôle proactif dans cette crise
vietnamienne
reste à savoir si cela sera suivi
d'effets dans les dents l'aise sur le
terrain
la zenn qui pour la première fois donc
formule des recommandations à un de ses
membres est ce que c'est un nouveau
tournant un nouveau rôle pour l'asian
oui tout à fait parce que l'un des ânes
dans le fond est venu à la politique par
l'économie au tout début de sa création
les premiers pays qui ont fondé la zean
la thaïlande les philippines singapour
était dans le fond une alliance anti
communiste pour contenir la progression
communiste dans le nord et le nord-est
de l'asie
et puis ensuite ils se sont élargies et
ils ont inclus des régimes aussi
différents que les trois régimes de
l'ancienne indochine vietnam laos
cambodge est ainsi d'ailleurs que la
birmanie à l'époque où elle était guéri
j'ai déjà par une junte de militaires et
progressivement en cherchant à réaliser
une sorte de marché commun économique
en tout cas au moins de zones de libre
échange économique
ils en sont venus à la politique tout
simplement parce que ils se sont aperçus
que la prospérité économique des
demandes est très étroitement de
l'instabilité politique et que s'il ya
des deshors alors de 4 caractères
externe comme en mer de chine du sud mer
de l'est comme des vietnamiens ou s'il y
avait des gens dans l'un des vêtements
par exemple en birmanie
ça remet en cause évidemment la
stabilité du pays la prospérité et donc
la déraison
de là des ânes et d'assurer la
prospérité et la stabilité
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre éclairage c'est l édito diplo
à retrouver tous les mardis matin dans
la matinale de rtl france